You have to be careful.
The hurricane could miss Louisiana altogether.
Yeah right.
Because we get what we expect.
I'm open to the possibility that whatever happens...
Oh my God.
...even the bad stuff can lead to better things.
I can't afford a new roof.
Let me help.
Why are you helping me?
Because I can.
How do you know Miranda?
I don't, really.
Why are you fixing her roof?
I just don't want you to blow this.
She doesn't love him.
Not like dad.
All your dad ever wanted was for you to be happy.
How would you know that?
What are you doing right now?
Taking in this gorgeous sunset.
I don't understand what's happening here.
I think you and I collided for a reason.
What's it say?
Mom, what happened to the bumper?
Karma.
Or maybe he's just a lousy driver.